gary got snippy with me this morning
really yeah because people call in and
go hey what'd you think of gary on uh
jimmy fallon and i go well okay let me
take a look at this you keyed in on one
line of a six-minute interview do you
collect a lot of stuff i collect
everything man my wife wants me to throw
everything away really i've got like 4
000 pieces of vinyl like 3 000 cds who
calls a record pieces of vinyl i never
heard that i said to gary this morning
this is what started this i said to gary
gary
just call them records that's what they
are when did you become this uh well
jimmy uh i have over four thousand
pieces of vinyl i think it's more fun to
make fun of me than it is to say a
problem
i said something positive and you said
nine things negative i don't know what
you want from me you screwed up when you
walked over you didn't realize how to
walk to the couch that's true that was
hysterical okay there's two ways to walk
he walked the wrong way
[Music]
are those clothes you're wearing or
pieces of cotton on the wrap-up show
yesterday several people called who said
of course they've heard that expression
before i think they're so because you
haven't heard it it couldn't have
possibly i didn't say that i said i've
never ever heard anyone refer to a
record as a pieces of vinyl i didn't
refer to a record it's a collection okay
i've never heard anyone refer to a
collection but other people have vinyl
other people have when did you begin
calling records pieces of vinyl i don't
know probably years ago years ago so you
said oh i have this many pieces yeah i
think where did you hear this term the
first time do you have any recollection
i don't i don't i could make up a lie
but i don't have an answer does anybody
else think this is silly fred personally
have you ever heard pieces of violence
and i'm trying to be honest here i've
never heard that expression until gary
said it i'm not saying that he's wrong
right i would have used the term either
albums or records yeah i said i've never
called my collection why would you call
records pieces of like wouldn't you just
go i mean
there's vinyl flooring
right it could be a thousand pieces of
vinyl flooring mixed in with my records
right yeah but i mean we've always been
called records why do you need a new
name for them i don't know it's like a
fan it sounds a little pretentious yeah
personally pieces of vinyl
i'll take that from fred it sounds
pretentious my question is if you walked
into a store saying i would like to buy
a piece no i would say i want to buy a
record but when you're done
you might say how many pieces of vinyl
you have in the store because it's
records of 45's
i'm just saying and the guy beat you up
[Laughter]
do you refer to your teeth as teeth or
pieces of ivory pieces pieces how many
pieces of ivory 32.
on your jimmy fallon appearance you were
the best
you